Hi.
My name is Hannes.
I'm here to talk about web Development in
China.
I have been doing web development since 2004.
If anybody remember this is.
I got bored of being in Hamburg and in Germany,
so in 2011 I ended up in China as a web developer.
And that was not completely my expression,
but it was a little bit my expression.
That's a screaming legal person there.
I felt like going back into the past a little
bit.
Because in 2011 when I arrived in China, I
had to deal with supporting IE6 again.
This is a world web of IE6 in 2011.
And you see this stop there I zoom this in
a little bit.
This is China with over like 30%.
So, I was already supporting IE6, if not many
more, and then I was right back supporting
IE6.
That was not great.
So, in the last several years, all of this
changed.
Now everybody is using a mobile phone pretty
much all the time.
And maybe you feel more comfortable booking
a flight ticket on a desk desktop or a laptop,
that's what I do.
In China, they do everything except work,
maybe, the majority does everything on the
mobile phone.
So, they're highly mobile optimized.
How does this happen that people actually
skipped computers?
It's the leapfrog effect.
The majority of people had cell phones.
And a generation skipped from a cell phone
over the desktop to having a computer in their
hand.
Having a smartphone.
So, a lot of people, the majority of people,
actually, never had a desktop at home.
They just had the smartphone.
This is why most people always use the smartphone
by now.
Before going to the talk, an overview of what
to talk about.
The three topics.
The mandatory part.
If you do projects for people in China, what
you need to take care of.
I talk about the important part, WeChat, the
number one social media app in China.
And I talk about the development ecosystem,
the community part in China.
I think this is the most interesting part.
I would like to know here in the audience,
who has been to China?
Okay.
Not too many people, actually.
So, for the people who have not been to China,
I'm going to pick you up there.
So, you've heard that stuff is blocked in
China, right?
Facebook, Tweeter, Google stuff is blocked.
But you don't know what that means.
Usually on a new country, you flip out your
phone and ask Google how to get to the hotel.
If you do that in China, this is how it looks.
You get the familiar blue spot, but nothing
else.
Google won't talk to you.
And even though you thought you would be prepared.
You might figure out, okay, maybe not that
prepared anymore.
Other people come to China a little bit more
prepared, like Mark Zuckerberg.
He runs over Tiananmen Square in Beijing and
was able to post it on Facebook so other people
come to China better prepared.
And now that you have an idea of how it feels
to be a tourist in China, I would like to
talk about the first project in China, the
project for people or users in China.
If your client tells you, hey, whack we do
soc that people in China can use our web page?
First of all, you might add translations.
Maybe webfonts on that page.
I have a client, they have print products
and we have a special one for Chinese characters.
Sending over here.
Having fonts for special Chinese characters
that we use for printing products.
Maybe we can transform that file and you can
use it on the Internet.
And I said, yes, that's a great idea.
Send it over.
They sent over a file and it was 50 megabyte.
Maybe not a good idea.
Chinese has a lot of characters, obviously.
So, they said, put it in anyway.
And I was like, maybe not.
So, the idea is, just use system fonts with
Chinese on your web page.
If you want to use a web font, make sure that
it's highly optimized.
Another thing is people like to have maps
on the page to show fancy things.
Usually they use Google Maps to implement
that.
And this is the company, we have branches
all over the world.
This is how it looks.
In China, it looks like this.
You don't see anything.
If you want to make sure that you have a map
and the Chinese audience can see it, you might
want to use alternatives to Google Maps.
For example, Mapbox still works.
Anyone from Mapbox in here?
Okay.
And maybe the better alternative is using
the Chinese provider.
In this case, Baidu maps.
This is reliable within China.
You have to have the Chinese translation,
but you can copy and paste code.
You sell stuff on your web page.
And why are none of the Chinese users now
that we translated stuff are buying stuff?
That's because you ask for western payment
that are not popular in China pretty much
at all.
Nobody is using these.
Maybe some, but obviously not the majority.
What do they use?
In real life, you see lines in shops and restaurants,
online, everywhere.
These three payment methods here.
If you want people from China not to be hesitant
to buy stuff on your page, implement at least
one of these on your page.
It's not that bad if you already use a payment
integration service like Stripe or Wirecard,
they offer one of these payment methods that
you can easily integrate.
And generally there is something hm.
Okay.
In general, it's always like a good idea to
hold stuff yourself.
If you use CDNs, content delivery networks
or web providers, make sure they're not blocked
in China.
And make that sure on a regular basis.
You never know when things are changing.
Maybe it's a better idea to host stuff in
general on your own server.
Then how to improve performance?
You can host in China.
It's going to be faster to load for the Chinese
users.
Well, in China, hosting is a little bit different.
Maybe you have seen the web page that has
the small numbers down here.
Zoom this in a little bit.
It says ICP.
Maybe you can't read it.
It says ICP, & there's a number.
It's Internet content provider and there's
basically somehow a number plate of your web
page.
So, it indicates who is responsible for the
content of your web page.
And, yes, if there's any issue, for example,
that happened to other people that I know,
you have a country selector and you list all
the countries in the world, including Hong
Kong and Taiwan, someone is going to call
you and say, please change that.
Otherwise we're going to block your page.
How to get this Internet content providing
number?
Well, you need a company in China.
You need an entity of a company in China or
a corporation partner that helps you with
applying to this doing this process of applying
for an ICP number.
And once you have done that, it takes a longer
time.
Maybe up to six, eight weeks.
Then you can legally host in China.
And that was my first topic already.
It was to talk about don't use web fonts for
Chinese, unless they're optimized, no Google
Maps, offer Chinese payment methods, host
for yourself and be if you want to host in
China, get a license.
And the next topic is WeChat.
Maybe you have heard of WeChat.
Maybe people told you it's like the WhatsApp
of China.
Maybe that was the case, but now it's changed.
And you use the different apps to do all kinds
of things on our mobile devices.
By now you could say that the majority of
these things or all these things can be done
in China by only using WeChat.
WeChat is created by a company called Tencent
and integrated into Chinese society.
How it's integrated into daily life.
I would like to show in real life examples.
Here is a QR code in the restaurant.
I open the WeChat, scan the QR code and I
can order food and pay, and it gets delivered
to my table.
I order coffee here with WeChat.
Here, these are like QR codes that you see
everywhere in restaurants that you use for
scanning and payment.
This is me doing this.
Scanning one of these QR codes and then paying
with WeChat.
You can also use that for street venders selling
foods or things on the street.
They're going to show a QR code and you can
pay with WeChat.
Basically, most of the Chinese people, or
maybe just, yeah.
Most of the Chinese people, they don't take
cash anymore.
They just need their phone and you go out
and you can do everything with your phone.
You can also rent bikes with it.
Maybe you have seen these bikes also in Berlin.
And you know that you have they already have
their own native apps to rent a bike here,
right?
But these are also, these functionalities,
are also integrated into WeChat.
Once you have WeChat and you can rent all
these bikes, you don't need the native app
anymore.
You can also do hospital appointments with
WeChat.
And the last thing that I figured out, apparently
you can get a divorce with WeChat.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah.
You can do a lot of things with WeChat.
And yeah.
To give you an idea of how this works.
Inside of WeChat, apart from the chat application,
I want to introduce how it looks like.
For example, here you have the mobile top
up thingy.
If you run out of data, you can top up your
data plan there.
There's something called utilities.
You get an overview.
It's Chinese here.
But it's an overview of your utility bills,
electricity, water, et cetera.
You can pay all of this with WeChat.
And there's another thing.
It's like third party operators.
These are being this is a default that comes
with WeChat.
You can buy flight tickets, order, get movie
tickets we buy food, et cetera, et cetera.
And usually all these services have their
own native apps, but once you can use this,
why would you install the native app, right?
So, when we talk mobile first, I talk to some
Chinese development friends and they said,
well in in WeChat?
In China you could talk about WeChat first.
Because you need to make sure that your stuff
it not working on the Safari browser.
It has to work inside of WeChat.
And you can also extend that functionality.
And before this was done by creating HTML
5 pages that will be opened in the internal
browser of WeChat and you can use an SDK and
do payment and do the QR code scanning and
stuff.
But I think I don't know.
One and a half years or one year ago they
created something called Tencent created WeChat
mini programs.
And they are basic life a better extension
a better way to extend the WeChat and write
your own stuff for WeChat.
And I'll give you an example.
It's the Chinese Yelp.
And this is the overview of WeChat.
And I'm asking for a recommendation for a
Beijing duck restaurant.
And they reply with a link.
And you get a preview.
And you click this, and the internal browser
opens and shows the detailed information of
the restaurant.
In this case, it says on the bottom, it says
mini program.
If I click this, not the internal browser
opens, but a loading layer opens for like
a second and then I get the information about
the Beijing restaurant.
It's a good duck restaurant.
And once you have done that and you installed
this mini program into WeChat, you can also
place that here on the right on your home
screen.
And if you click it here, you get the Chinese
Yelp in the mini chat layer.
It has a third party app.
But as I said, once you can do the majority
of things with the program, why would you
install to the native app or go to the mobile
site?
You're using WeChat all the time anyway.
And you might say how this reminds me of a
PWA.
And, yes, you're right.
Because you can use it offline.
You can add it to your home screen and it's
really highly performance optimized and loads
really fast.
But in this case, it's a little bit special.
So, I call it WeChat apps, by exchanging the
W. It is a little bit special here.
Because these things are not hosted on your
own servers.
These mini programs are hosted on the Tencent
server, behind WeChat.
It's all over the world and delivered and
opened very fast in WeChat.
There's an initial size of 1 megabyte.
And it's not 100% web technology.
It's web view and native components from WeChat.
Payment and QR code scanning and some other
stuff.
Yeah.
Tencent, how do you create such a new program?
Tencent decided to create their own JavaScript.
It's called WeLang.
It's closed source.
It uses WXML.
WSS in JavaScript.
It's pretty much HTML and CSS in JavaScript.
They called it differently.
And as I said, it compiles into a mix of native
code and others.
They created their own enter.
This is the preview, this is how you write
code, the debugging.
Looks like the Chrome DevTools.
Yes, it's a modified version of the Chrome
Dev Tools I would say.
This is the code for hello world.
It's not big enough.
So, I'm going to show you two slides of code
only, so you know how this WeLang looks like
so you're not afraid of using it.
This is the WXML.
HTML template.
Maybe people say it looks familiar.
It looks a bit like VUE JS.
And this is the CSS.
And this is the JavaScript part.
There's just a data property and I have the
hello world and that's it.
And after you load the initial kind of JavaScript,
you can do some other functionalities.
You get user information and stuff and stuff.
So, you see it's not like that different.
Bootstrap, this is pretty much the bootstrap
of WeChat.
They provide some UX elements that you can
use to style it in a way that it looks like
WeChat.
Yes.
That was the WeChat part.
What am I talking about?
Talking about WeChat, the number one in China.
There are others, but this is the most important.
I introduced WeChat and the payment and the
aspects of WeChat in programs.
And this brings me to the last part?
How much time do I have left?
Do I have ten minutes?
I have two minutes left?
Wow.
Okay.
This is the important part.
Four minutes left.
Okay.
Cool.
This is the interesting part.
The ecosystem.
The community of China.
When I came to China in 2011 I was going to
conferences and meetups and exchanging knowledge.
I had the feeling that was not the case in
2011.
Not a lot of conferences and meetups.
And people stuck to their own knowledge to
keep their place safe in a way.
By now this all changed.
They have their own conference.
JavaScript, VUE, React, CSS, et cetera.
They have a lot of meetups in the bigger cities
and they exchange knowledge way more than
before.
They also created their own platforms.
Because when we use StackOverflow, we are
comfortable using English more or less.
But for the majority, there are a lot of Chinese
developers that are fluent in English.
But the majority, I would say they don't feel
comfortable using English all the time.
So, they can use this to search stuff and
copy and paste code as we all do.
But once you ask a question here in English,
you can imagine how it works out, so they
created their own StackOverflow.
It's green and it's in Chinese.
And it's easier to use, right?
If you're Chinese.
No, but this is not the biggest platform.
I wanted to show this because of the name
and the similarities.
What they actually use is not Quro, but Baidu.
This is used to exchange knowledge.
This is the creator of VUE JS, he's Chinese
and has accounts on all the platforms.
Not only western ones, but the Chinese ones.
And, yes, they created open source.
You have big companies in China creating open
source.
All of this open source is being done in English.
There's a documentation, communication, issue
handling being done in English.
But the Chinese open source is completely
done in Chinese.
And they have to cater for a specific requirement.
So, they have to be highly mobile focused.
They really need to scale.
Because if you're a startup and become successful
overnight in Germany, maybe add a half million
users.
Successful in China, you can add 50 million
users overnight.
This is interesting for developers inside
and outside of China.
So, they want to use this as well.
But now we noticed that not only Chinese have
an issue being comfortable in English.
But there's an issue of us feeling comfortable
in Chinese.
And in these open source projects, these issues
appear.
Can we have English, please?
Or, documentation and read me should be in
English because, because, because.
And even better, and this is not a native
English speaker, so this is why he doesn't
understand what that means.
He says, guys, please use English.
And I say this a little bit because there's
a funny answer to this.
The answer says this is the best time to start
learning Mandarin.
Maybe it is.
Maybe that's the solution.
Learn Mandarin.
Fuck.
This is hard.
Maybe not the best option to do that.
What can we do?
Well, everyone knew we had to figure that
out.
Evan You says it lacks in documentation of
learning resources for English speakers.
We intend to bridge this gap next year.
That's important to bridge the gap.
Not only Chinese and English, but all the
directions.
How do we do this?
Well, we create and this is another Chinese
open source project.
We created a task, document translation.
Looking for volunteers who can help out.
And I think this is so important that we do
this because it doesn't only make it easier
for people from not speaking Chinese to use
your project, for people all over the world.
Developers all over the world to use your
project.
But I think these kinds of tasks are also
a great way with a low entrance barrier to
participate in open source.
Because maybe you don't feel too comfortable
of writing great JavaScript.
But you speak two languages, and this is your
first step into open source.
You can start helping to translate stuff and
maybe slowly getting into more of that.
So, I think this is a great thing.
And VUE is doing this really great.
And VUE is very popular in China.
That's maybe because the creator is actually
Chinese.
But also, I think, VUE in general is doing
a great job in documentation and translations.
I read an article because there's a huge community
in China.
But I read an article that there used to be
a big problem of channeling back knowledge
from the Chinese community to the American
or the international because of this language
barrier.
You don't have this in VUE.
So, I think if this continues, we are just
going to use VUE soon because they do a really
great job on this.
No, it's just a joke.
So, VUE is very popular and I think it's getting
popular all over the world.
But yeah.
They do a really good job on translation documentation.
And that was the last part we were going to
talk about.
I talked about the shift from not sharing
knowledge to actually sharing knowledge, having
conferences, having meetups.
Creating their own platforms to exchange and
share knowledge.
I talked about the language barrier of both
sides.
And I said talked about how to enable developers
by providing and even more people by providing
dedicated translation tasks.
And that's it.
Thank you very much.
I'm done.
[ Applause ]
Oh.
If you if you
[ Applause ]
Thanks.
If you have any feedback, let me know.
[speaking in Mandarin]
[ Applause ]